welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
boston zack snyder's justice league
revealed
black suit superman in a teaser clip
that i'm gonna break down with a boss
cut
and real quick i'm super excited to
announce that omaze is offering you the
chance to win
a 20 000 dream pc taxes and shipping are
included and even better
every donation but if it's a great cause
all you have to do is go to omaze.com
rockstars and enter for your chance to
win okay let's roll that new snyder cut
clip
i'm assuming you're awkward now you
might have seen a fuller version of this
clip released as a deleted scene by the
studio after the theatrical cut came out
the key difference being of course
superman's suit is red and blue in that
version
i'm assuming you're alfred
master kent this is also the moment the
studio used as a stinger at the end of
their 2017 comic con sneak peek which
was after snyder had left the project
he said you'd come now let's
hope you're not too late so in the
timeline of the movie storyline this
would have been
after batman wonder woman cyborg aquaman
and flash went off to fight steppenwolf
and after superman had resurrected and
in snyder's version of the film superman
would have returned to the kryptonian
chamber and gotten this black suit which
was also a deleted scene released after
the theatrical version came out and then
that superman would have worn this black
suit when he flew to bruce's mansion and
found alfred to catch up on what is
going on now according to snyder
superman would need a new suit because
doomsday tore a huge gash in the red and
blue one
with a spike and in the comics superman
resurrects first wearing a black suit
for healing purposes it makes them
absorb solar energy more efficiently
and recover faster but this black suit
evolution went fully misunderstood by
the studio
according to snyder who said that they
wouldn't pay for the manufacture of a
practical black suit for some reason the
perception of the black seed made
everyone see like
oh it's just like that sounds like
you're just trying to make a you know
the movie
you know dark and scary evil superman
not hilarious
and i said well yeah no it's not
hilarious
and to account for this snyder said that
he shot the scene with henry cavill
in the red and blue costume but with
specific coloring specific lighting
so that it would be easier to recolor
the suit in black and gray tones in
post-production he even pointed this out
when they replayed the clip
see how you see that kind of charcoal in
the cake yeah he's pointing out how the
original color temperature between the
red and the blue
was adjusted to make the red even warmer
than usual
so that the cape would come off as a
contrasting shade of charcoal
from the deeper blacks of the rest of
the suit now snyder confirmed that his
current cut of justice league
is 214 minutes long that's three hours
and 34 minutes
and that he plans to reveal at dc's
fandom event on august 22nd whether it
will release as a single film
or an episodic mini-series on hbo max
and what the official title will be
zack snyder's justice league is the
preferred title but he said that there
was some legal issues that have to work
out and those legal issues are most
likely the fact that most directors are
contractually work for hire they don't
own their movies or the copyright to
them the movies legally belong to the
studios so it's like a whole thing about
billing the director's name in the title
of the content
most interestingly snyder talked about
how this process has been a restorative
one
restoring the original artistic intent
rather than
filming new additional material to add
to it he said that he originally
conceived the movie to be shot in the
imax
aspect ratio of 143-1 a more vertical
frame than the
widescreen aspect ratio of two three
nine to one his reasoning is that
superheroes tend to be more towering
vertical shapes
whose movement goes along a y-axis as
opposed to most other cinema imagery
moving left to right
along an x-axis ironically joss whedon
applied this same reasoning for shooting
the first avengers movie in an aspect
ratio of one eight
to 1 taller than other mcu films so that
in a single frame we could take in
taller heroes like hulk along with
grounded ones like black widow hawkeye
cap and with like vertically shaped
take-offs from iron man or thor
but i guess when warner brothers hired
whedon to take over after schneider left
that whole principle got
lost in the luggage at the airport
snyder actually illustrated this with a
sketch of batman that he did how he
storyboarded it one way but how a
widescreen re-edit would crop out
important visual details and we saw an
actual example of this with the hbo max
teaser clip with diana in
darkseid's history but in the dark
among the stars notice the first shot of
that wall with the torch does reveal
in the corner greek lettering at the top
of the frame letters that actually
translate
to dark side but cropped in widescreen
the letters wouldn't be revealed in the
wide and then we wouldn't see them until
they just suddenly appear out of nowhere
in a close-up
also this big master shot of darkseid on
the battlefield wouldn't give us the
whole scope of his fleet or that
apocalyptic pillar of flame
and thanks to omaze for sponsoring this
video enter for your chance to win
twenty thousand dollars to build your
ultimate dream pc
while supporting a great charity by
going to omaze.com
rockstars and using the code rockstars50
for 50 additional entries omaze's model
democratizes traditional auction giving
by offering everyone the chance to have
a once-in-a-lifetime experience that
also benefits a charity
through the omaze platform people from
more than 180 countries have made
donations that support over
350 charities driving awareness for the
charities work and raising more money
than traditional methods
they've given over 130 million dollars
to charity and their goal is to raise a
billion dollars for charity in a single
year
on omaze you can enter to win a tesla a
vacation in new zealand or have a
virtual play date with big bird while
supporting charities like make a wish or
the boys and girls club omaze is
offering you the chance to win
an ultimate dream pc use it for gaming
film editing graphic design whatever you
like
taxes and shipping are included and even
better every donation benefits a great
cause
gamers outreach a charity that does
awesome work with the gaming community
to provide recreation to children in
hospitals so for your chance to win the
ultimate pc of your dreams go to
omaze.com
rockstars and enter now every donation
supports gamer's outreach so hurry up
that's omaze.com
rockstars go there donate and good luck
snyder explained that the black suit
evolution of superman wasn't about
making him evil or edgy but to humanize
him
i want him on a full in
full volume in full spectrum of emotion
i don't want him like one note boy scout
like i'm here to like help everyone you
hear the words of
jorel and you hear the words of park
kent trying to keep him on
on on track and we all get distracted
and pushed and
pulled by like the world and we have
this great ideas and we get turned into
something else
but on to some other big reveals from
this justice con panel
first green lantern snyder shook his
head when he was asked to confirm or
deny if green lantern would appear in
the film he's keeping those lips sealed
for now but he did acknowledge that he
did include a green lantern easter egg
on the merch released last december
sure did do that didn't that now this
most likely refers to the reported early
cut post-credits scene that would have
shown green lantern corps members
kilawog and tamara ray greeting bruce
wayne at his mansion to warn him about
darkseid
that hoodie also includes a logo for
martian manhunter with both snyder and
man of steel actor harry lennox
confirming that he was being planned as
a dceu's martian manhunter
who could have tied into the next
justice league film during justice khan
snyder also revealed more about his
vision for the villain steppenwolf
who yeah and the theatrical cut ended up
being kind of a half-baked cgi potato
with little depth or motivation but
snyder said he conceived him to be a
more fearsome
warrior desperate for darkseid's
approval all the previous is the old
steppenwolf you know with this crazy
armor and everything
so like you know it's underneath so you
just look underneath you're like oh cool
look that's how we
we're going to originally do it he's a
spikey
[Laughter]
he's not humanoid so he really doesn't
care he'll like tear your arms off he
literally doesn't care
he just wants darkseid to accept him and
and take him back
snyder is referring to a more extended
backstory with steppenwolf and darkseid
darkseid who in his youth went under the
name oxis or oxis snyder actually joked
how there's disagreement over the
canonical pronunciation so the only name
people would call him in this film is
darkseid
including yeah diana's greek lettering
on the wall there but this backstory
would include
young darkseid fighting in that ancient
amazonian war
imagery shown in that hbo max teaser and
we will see how darkseid's mother hegra
will have her spirit encased in the
three mother boxes
explaining why her son and her brother
steppenwolf darkseid's uncle
are so eager to retrieve them
steppenwolf was hoping to get back in
darkseid's good graces
by rescuing hagra's soul snyder revealed
his cut will feature much more of victor
stone's cyborg
like his time playing football and the
experimentation with his father
silas at star labs but snyder revealed
that he recolored all the cyborg
sequences in black and white
inspired by a black and white
promotional billboard for the character
snyder also said that the original
composer junkie xl was working insanely
hard to complete
his restored score for the film and
finally in case there was any confusion
snyder said that he'd rather burn
the whole project than use a single
frame from whedon's reshoots i would
destroy the movie i would set it on fire
before i would use a single frame that i
did not photograph
and i assume that includes anything shot
by second unit director stock imagery or
any of the art of photography that might
show up in the background
this needs to be pure snyder everything
else watch it
ben now we will be doing a full
breakdown of the longer snyder cut
teaser when it comes out in august until
then join our official discord server by
becoming a patreon at
patreon.comrockstars we'll be talking
about this
a lot follow me on instagram at eavos
follow new rockstars and socials and
subscribe to this channel
and let's end with a little fact check
here snyder was wrong about whedon not
using any vertical framing i mean
whedon's opening shot was in portrait
mode
so maybe instead of burning it let's
just keep the smartphone footage and
restore the stash
yes cut
[Music]
you